this is a great indoor outfit when you
want to look stylish at an event it is
not the best walking outside in Los
Angeles during the day outfit I'm a
pretty big NBA fan I've been watching
for as long as I can remember
I love the NBA since I was a kid I grew
up watching basketball I feel like this
is gonna be a really unique experience
for me I'm definitely like aware of the
NBA how can you not be and I do like
follow them kind of more related to
their celebrity not as much their actual
game
I feel like an NBA player style is very
different from my style
I am definitely into fashion and into
style I think my style is pretty chill I
usually wear like a lot of black and
dark blue and gray one of my favorite
players in the NBA because he's just
kind of wild to me is James Harden I
think he is for some reason just
hilarious he's just very showy Russell
Westbrook in particular pulls off a lot
of stuff that I just I feel like that
Duke can make anything look dope this is
absolutely going to push me out of my
comfort zone which is why I think it's
any fun okay I love it all very
fashionable guys today is day one today
I'm supposed to dress like Kawhi Leonard
this should be the easiest of the days I
think I looked up a bunch of photos of
Kawhi and apparently all this dude wears
his sweats I think it's a bit tough for
me especially cuz he like isn't really
in my opinion particularly fashionable
Kawhi love you but sorry no he is not a
complicated man fashion wise it kind of
makes it harder because for the
challenge I still want to feel like I'm
putting together some kind of specific
outfit not just like sweatpants in a
sweatshirt a couple of things you
noticed about Christ style was that he
wears a lot of muted colors grays and
blacks and does
you can really accessorize in any
capacity I also notice that he wear
socks like visible socks so I really
thought it was important that I
incorporated that into my outfit why is
wearing in my it's very difficult to put
baby food so clearly I it's the perfect
outfit America I got these socks but I'm
gonna wear today with it and we'll see
if anybody notices that I'm dressed
differently
I still think it'll look you know
fashionable but I think they'll be
thrown off by the socks Kauai is he's a
New Balance guy so I know the Reebok
wouldn't fly I guess the Nike stuff
wouldn't either
but we got black puffy coat we got the
like same color blue sweatshirt it's not
a hoodie but focus I could do grey
joggers some light low tops I feel like
it's pretty close the camera does not
need to be on me right now it needs to
be on these socks because I'm a fun guy
you're okay those are very fun guys
socks oh yeah listen here's what
happened I went to a New Balance event
recently for Kawhi Leonard and I got a
bunch of stuff that way I did not
actually because I can't get over these
socks do you think I look like any
particular NBA player because of the
wild colors I'm gonna go for maybe
Russell Westbrook possibly : yes Kawhi
you're like the first person yeah you
know I got it okay honestly you
definitely killed it so today's player
is LeBron James and I'm quickly
realizing that my wardrobe does not have
stuff that imitates an NBA player so I
might have to do some slight shopping I
actually had to purchase my first item
which was his hat because it seems like
LeBron wears hats like this it's my
first time wearing a big hat I usually
just do baseball hats or beanies it's
different it's a look it's not when I
feel great about on myself but uh
do it anyway I had a really hard time
figuring out what I was gonna do because
his style is very masculine it's like
straight out of GQ LeBron and Kawhi are
the two that I think I can do without
buying anything so yeah I picked out
this photo my only concern is the shoes
he has like some pretty wild shoes on
and I don't have anything that really
looks like those okay as you can see
here I have chosen a lot of different
hits earth-tone type pieces I don't have
the exact same that I'm sure it
obviously but this one's similar is a
denim shirt white shirt is like some
black acid-wash kind of jeans the
closest I can get and then some bronze I
feel really good about this someone
helped me and I made this key adjustment
by like tilting their hat back because
before I had a like all the way on I
feel like that's not the cool way to
wear it but I actually found the real
abundant here look at this wow he
definitely loves layers and hoodies and
I was actually thinking about doing
something like this
but then I was like I wear that all the
time well you know listen I am I needed
a channel to enter after in Ohio at me
Oh
do you think I look like an NBA player
now if you had to guess what NBA player
I look like do you have any idea so your
guest for the NBA player I'm dressed
like today is Marshawn Lynch
oh you don't yeah he's a big retired
running back in the NFL wow it really
feels like I'm actually looking right at
him look at this hat and this roll up of
this sock so today is Dwayne Wade day
was a huge fan of him throughout his
entire career not just on the court but
his fashion he does a lot of like GQ and
stuff so the dude really knows how to
dress I think this is like the sweet
spot of where it's normal-ish clothing
but you're getting fancier with it Wayne
Wade has a really cool style really chic
style and he loves to coordinate I did
think of something that I haven't worn
in years the stuff in my closet and it's
a look in a suit like a khaki suit I
found a blazer and then put a plain tea
under it because I saw that he does that
a lot and then I have some pants they're
a little high watery because he has a
lot of exposed ankle no socks so I have
some notes show socks and some shoes so
it's like a blazer but then also kind of
casual there's photo of do a I think is
like a matte gala or something he's
wearing this black suit with like a
black hoodie it's like simple but it's
elevated a little bit the hood situation
I already have some stuff to kind of do
that do you like the Blazer
well thank you that's kind of a
compliment and that's the best I'm gonna
get from you so appreciate that okay
initial thoughts on the Dwyane Wade
outfit is it's very hot this is a great
indoor outfit when you want to look
stylish at an event it is not the best
walking outside in Los Angeles during
the day outfit okay so today I meant to
dress like Russell Westbrook
I was running super late this morning so
I put together an outfit I feel pretty
good about it
it's very extra Russell Westbrook has
amazing style but he is so crazy
he always has one thing that like just
doesn't belong I feel like I just looked
like a dude in a flannel with cutoff
sleeves I went for a very specific look
for the base layer we got this guy this
is not a shirt I would normally buy but
I'm actually super dig it and I think
it's a lot of fun boom I got this guy
sounds these sweet little rips in it
which I feel like is very Russ so I
already have these jeans like a light
acid wash kind of kind of vibe I feel
like this is very in line with what if
people said about what you're wearing
you know what they said I have a drip
it's a lot of dress I really like this
outfit on me and I feel like that's
amazing because I was pretty insecure
wearing this out of the house but I
think like now I feel good I have been
getting a lot of compliments that feel
like when your mom wants to make you
feel good about yourself because your
outfits not that dope I think it looks
great
I actually think she has a lot more
sauce anyways like this okay obviously
the first thing I'm gonna do in my
Westbrook outfit is do what I assume he
does when he gets dressed up like this
which is a go to the grocery store
shopping for groceries looking cool as
hell this James Harden day as you can
see I got a shirt on this is not
typically the type of thing I was we're
both in size and in color I decided to
go and replicate his this like orange
and light blue look that I found he's
actually wearing jeans in it but I
decided to kind of change it up and I
went with a bright orange dress matching
orange shoes and then I'm wearing like a
long like overcoat that's made of like
them this is another one that I
definitely had to buy stuff for I kind
of used this photo as inspiration for me
it's like I like that he had the same or
similar pattern over a piece with the
same pattern it was like Paragon pattern
the brynan version of it is I think I'm
gonna go with black pants this is the
top for James it's a big bold pattern
and then over that I'm going BAM floral
jacket too I think you're looking
stylish guys now you think of my outfit
today scale one to ten that's what
everyone said I've met one of you ever
see me wear something in this baggy I
know which picture you were basing this
off of in your nail
and I'm kind of jealous because everyone
just thinks I'm wearing a baggy shirt
and dress like no do you follow the NBA
at all yes if you had to guess what NBA
player I'm today are you restless red
clothes if not rust and whoo yeah I
think I can see it okay 1 to 10 how
would you how would you rate my James
Harden outfit every time at scale of
like how James Harden are you or how
James Harden James Harden are you I'll
give you up at 9 at a time oh well your
dress it's not an attitude I think it
went really well I know personally I got
a lot of reactions that were very
positive and unexpected it was
definitely challenging like I have not
put this much thought into making an
outfit in a very long time this week was
a lot of fun I definitely wore a lot of
stuff that I never would have worn
normally I'll actually got like more
compliments on these outfits than I have
and like outfits that I actually wear so
maybe it was a good lesson I didn't
really realize that like I would feel
stress about wearing something that I
felt weird in like I thought it would
just be funny and like on a lark I'm
surprised that I found a way to combine
their style with mine in a way that most
of the time I really liked the biggest
takeaway from this is I would highly
recommend just like next time you go
shopping even if it's just like one item
that is very different from what you
normally wear I highly recommend it even
if only to get a reaction from your
friends and see what they say to you but
I promise you it'll probably be positive
[Music]